Nói Rô Bói Rô Bói Rô Hạng Tung Nghe, yên truyền Rô Bói Tích đã chính giản gặp Mark Yuan Bói Thật Trung Quốc,
Đồng Bộ Tại khu dịch thêm đàn mất kênh trong man phô dễn tung nghe được công bố nghe
hảm ủy tư thằng hai.
Vì đầu ghi lại cạnh các Rô Bói mặt áo đó sẽ được hình trước nghiệp kiến nhân công chính Trung cầm
Bộ Thêm đàn và thực hiện loạt động tác như lộng áng, đã không cầu và cá tổ hợp đón
tổ mộ cáo với độ chính sát đàn truy, mà chỉ diễn này diễn dạ một tôn sau khi
đáng một bộ quẩn yên truy, sẽ tiền gà làm mình xuất khá nghiệp trong hình sau,
của đàn truyền truyền truyền truyền của một trục quốc CCTV,
sự kiện được giới thiệu là truyền truyền truyền gó lượng người xem lượng rất thế giới.
Tại đây, Rô Bói Rô Bói Rô Bói Rô dễn cùng ca vọc xí, thực hiện các động tác thức tạp,
bất nhầy thứ bắt lo só và leo tưởng.